yeah we all know that music welcome back
to CBS mornings today we have a very
special Talk of the table for you it's
about something everyone is talking
about the Ted lasso season three finale
and we have a special guest joining us
actor Phil dunster who plays Jamie
Jamie
I love it in this clip Jamie and Coach
Ted lasso discussed Jamie's absent
father watch
well if you could talk to him right now
what would you say let's see
yeah make sense anything else yeah yeah
I see
thank you
you know Jamie is hating the pops ain't
motivating like it used to it might be
time to try something different
he's forgiven
I ain't giving him nothing
so powerful only on CBS mornings we like
when we can say that Phil dunster joins
us now and yes oh man we have to warn
you you might hear some Ted lasso
spoilers if you haven't seen the finale
turn off your Channel or just turn the
volume down turn the volume down
keep your TV off you're right you're
right uh Phil dunster welcome
thank you very much thank you I'm so
glad that you chose a clip where I swear
twice in it that that's
it's really hard to not find a clip
where you uh or breakfast are not
swearing but let me ask you I mean how
are you feeling now uh at the end of the
season at the end of the show just
describe the emotions what was it like
when when they finally said you know cut
and that was the last scene that you all
filmed
or terrifying because then we're all
unemployed and that you know that's uh
that was the worst thing about it really
but I mean it was it was a combination
of what was I think probably for
everybody involved in the show from cast
writer's crew
it was a sort of really Monumental thing
for us in our careers and our lives and
everybody's lives sort of changed over
that period
um but largely the the cast and crew
were all sort of the same uh from start
to finish yeah obviously there was there
was a shifts there but to to be there in
the locker room that same locker room
that we were from the first season
um yeah it was sad it was lots of crying
it's a comedy I can't believe how many
people cry watching a comedy but yeah we
get away with it that is so true Phil
that's so true what part of the beauty
of this show is that it tugs in your
heartstrings in ways you don't see
coming and the thing about your
character because first Jamie was such a
jerk in the beginning and then at the
end of episode season one you see the
backstory with his father and then my
heart totally changed against changed in
favor of him what was the evolution like
for you as his character and how do you
feel about how it's all turned out for
Jamie how do you feel
oh
I want to hear all of you do his accent
after this by the way there will be a
test no fair can do it yeah yeah they
like they like to grill the English
accent but yeah go on yeah
uh it's mysterious over there
um uh yeah well I mean it's interesting
even the clip that you showed you see
um it's it's not straightforward it's a
complicated emotional thing that Jamie's
always going through and for all the
characters and I think that from an
audience perspective I think that that's
the exciting and interesting thing if it
was just a really linear storyline or
sort of character Arc then it'd be quite
boring I think you'd want to feel like a
it's realistic for us we go it's not as
simple as going I learned the lesson and
then I put it into practice and
everything's better now you know you
learn the lesson you try you might fail
but you try again
um after that so it's it's a very
satisfying story and it's you know no
one no one really knows if it's the end
of the show or not we don't we just we
don't know but certainly at the end of
the chapter and Phil we just talked
about it was we joke about accents but
people may be surprised to find out
you're putting on an accent for your
character I'm originally from Milton
Keynes I know you're from Northampton so
I don't know if that makes us friends or
foes but what do you make of that well
you have to put that Accent on some more
for the sequels
or the movie
go ahead Spill the Beans bill
yeah this is this is the exclusive
um no no it's uh we don't know we really
don't know
um and we don't know if I'm putting on
an accent now which is the real accent
you tell me but
um but no I mean it's it that it really
is up to now I think that everybody is
just like
you know it's been such a wonderful
experience and we're happy just to sort
of take stock and we we bow down to
Jason stakis and Joe Kelly and Brendan
hunt who are the creators on the show
and go it's it's up to you guys if
there's something else that if there's
more of this story that needs to be told
we implicitly trust you
um but if not if that's all she wrote
then great we we you know yeah we that's
what I thought philosophical to be
honest with you Phil that's what I
thought was the beauty of how it wrapped
up on my TV it didn't say season finale
it said series finale which made me
think that it was the end but the way
that it wrapped up it would be
satisfying then but it also left the
door open if you wanted it to continue
as you sit here today would you like it
to continue would you like a spin-off or
you said I know you said it's up to
Jason all those guys but how are you
feeling about how it's wrapped up are
you ready
yeah it's a wonderful thing of course if
there was if there was more to be done
but if it was done with Integrity you
know I think that we've all done these
we've all loved shows and then they go
on and do five six seven eight seasons
or you know various different cinematic
universes and you sort of end up
resenting them slightly because you're
like oh no but that's I loved it so much
and how would you you know and I'm sure
that if we did do anything more it would
be it would be done with Integrity but
um but uh yeah no I I have nothing left
for it I knew that wasn't your I knew
that wasn't your real haircut what you
wear on the show so it's so nice to see
you yeah you look very nice Mr dunster
very nice
uh thank you very much uh wishing you
well you can watch yeah Ted lasso on
Apple TV plus hi Phil very cool